there's no time
13 o clock
[Music]
hey out there we're back again and it's
episode 170 which you know I can't
believe we're up 270 already so we'll
soon we'll be at the 200th episode yeah
I mean we're gonna have to think it's
something to do like I said I would had
a couple people ask us to do like maybe
a live stream or something like that
which we might do cuz we've been talking
about doing that for a long time and you
know maybe we'll get yeah
I can't we went by so fast yeah really a
hundred 70 episodes that's ridiculous
it's crazy
as ridiculous we're ridiculous well on
this particular episode of the show you
know as I said we kind of on in on the
early episodes of the show we kind of
did stuff about maybe slightly more
obscure serial killers and weird crimes
and stuff like that but we've kind of
been trying to go back and do something
like the better known serial killers I
guess because you've had so many
requests for them and stuff so on this
one we're going to be talking about the
Boston Strangler yeah now the Boston
Strangler was allegedly Albert DeSalvo
and I say allegedly because um I don't
know if I quite realize this until I
start started delving into this case
Albert DeSalvo was technically never
convicted of any of the canonical
strangler it's it's a weird case I
forgot all the details I think he was
linked to one of them later on yes but
that doesn't mean II got all of them
although I kind of do I mean I think
nowadays there's still some controversy
over how many people he actually did
kill and if he was responsible for some
of the crimes or all of them or one of
them or none of them or whatever um I
you know I kind of have my own opinions
on the matter which I guess I'll get
into later on like I said I didn't work
on the case I don't know but you know I
I definitely have ideas and one in line
with one particular outcome yeah you got
Dennis with us - yeah dennis is here -
yeah give us some insight yeah we won't
waste actually started to show without
Dennis I know we had to start over yeah
it was just in a few minutes it's a
people
yeah we only recorded like a minute a
half yeah sometimes I like some people
the YouTube comments of like asses were
because I think one time we forgot to
put them on camera like if you go to the
escape I'm like you gotta well you got
to watch this little [ __ ] here because
you know you never know and you might be
like running around like the Zuni
warrior late at night when you're not
like [ __ ] sleep we got get her one
with us - yeah yeah though both and he
can like keep denison present guard yeah
alright so but before we get into the
long convoluted complicated case of the
Boston Strangler only just got like a
couple of shout outs as I have mentioned
before my fiction collection of horror
fiction
The Associated villanies has been
re-released in print and ebook with you
know all little mistakes fixed and like
a nicer layout and stuff like that I
also have done an audiobook for audio
birth version but yes
Oh God has only I've only just now
started drinking so uh so yeah so yeah
so I did an audiobook version too so if
you've ever been interested in listening
to me read any of my own fiction then
you can go over and pick that one up
like I said I will be working on all my
other ones as time goes on I'm kind of
slowly trying to get all of my fiction
up on audiobook but you know it's a long
process and stuff like that um I'm also
considering and this will probably be a
couple months down the line but I'm
considering doing like not another
channel but just like another playlist
of videos of kind of scary stories just
like reading them and having you know
kind of like spooky visuals and stuff
just because I like stuff so much like
mr. nightmare and stuff like that where
you because I was listening to that all
on Halloween and some of that's true
stories and some of its fictional I
probably will just like mix them up with
like a theme on each thing but like I
said I've been working on some
those I have one episode almost done and
I'll probably have like a bunch of them
in the can like before I start putting
them up I might put them up once a week
or you know once every couple weeks or
something like that but you know that's
something that I've been kind of
thinking about doing cuz it sounded like
kind of fun also um I would like to give
a shout out to Hayden for his PayPal
donation this week okay we got a new one
so thank you very much yes it is so you
know if anybody wants to do that same
kind of thing like I said you can go to
our blog and there's a little button in
the sidebar
it says PayPal on it and we've got a
patreon too and get to the point we have
so many subscribers that if people just
said as a dollar it make a difference
now yeah definitely we had we have a
like a hardcore crew of patrons if I can
pay as a lot of money and they've been
contributing for everything for training
for a long time so if everybody else
wants to pull a little bit of weight
just send us a dollar on patreon a month
that make a big difference cuz you have
these almost 8000 subscribers now yeah
so yeah and I'm not really what yeah
anything would help now yeah yeah and
I'm not really sure to because I think
some people just listen to the audio
podcast like on write tunes and stuff
like that and I don't know how many
people listen to that because I always
yeah I know that when we when we had
that podcast counter when we were with
that other what was the network that
network we were getting like 50,000
downloads yeah we working member that
yeah like a day yeah so I'm not sure how
many we have now cuz I always kind of
cross check I've you know I usually just
check on the YouTube stuff and answer
yeah there isn't even a counter on that
one is it there maybe but I have yet to
find it okay well in place like I said
what you know what I do with the audio
version of the podcast is I just upload
it to archive and it just kind of goes
to a feed that like gives it to all
different so it's you know yeah far as I
know you I mean you get it on iTunes
you're gonna pod being you can get it on
pretty much any okay of the big podcast
platforms 500 thousands of jump it
wouldn't be like there's hundred
thousands people listen to her
yeah we're not really rambling and we're
just like and especially I'm sure you
gotta lose something like maybe just
listen to the audio podcast because you
can't see all the stupid [ __ ] that we do
on camera yeah and you can't see a
little Dennis and all
yeah we and we didn't set up the we
didn't set up the set like we did the
last couple yeah it's like it's Saturday
night it's getting late I'm like house
too lazy to like learning all the chairs
so we're gonna yeah we're gonna knock
this show out yeah so alright so you
want to get into talking about the
Boston Strangler case yeah
this occurred from 1962 to 1964 this
series of crimes it's usually between 8
and 8 and what am I talking about
between 11 and 13 murders that are
considered attributable to the Boston
Strangler as I said there still exist
some controversy over how many of them
Albert DeSalvo actually did if he indeed
did any of them although one of them
they know for pretty much almost certain
that he did it also they're not entirely
sure if that was all one person there's
still some controversy about that one
too because you know the first series of
crimes is a different victim profile
like some of the crimes had different a
little bit of a different modus operandi
and things like that so we'll kind of
get into all that later on let me guess
this happened in Boston no how'd you
guess that would be fine that [ __ ]
happened in Philadelphia he was like we
just decided to go in the Moscow just to
be an [ __ ] yeah that would be but yes
so these this series of murders took
place between June 1962 in January 1964
it was all 13 single women all of whom
were killed in their own apartments and
there were a lot of similarities but
like I said there's still controversy
over how many killers there were which
ones that Albert DeSalvo was responsible
for one thing that is kind of you know
the same across all the cases is that in
none of the murders was there signs of
forced entry meaning that whoever the
killer was they were able to wangle
their way into the apartment either that
or the victims knew them but I'm
thinking that it's probably the first
thing it was able to like saying he was
a maintenance man or something like that
that he was able to get in any apart
somehow so as I said even though Albert
DeSalvo is called the Boston Strangler
he was never officially convicted of any
of the canonical Boston Strangler
murders although he did confess to all
of them while he was in custody for
something else so that's why he's
associated with it and like I said you
know to this day he's some of his family
members still insists that he was
innocent they didn't have anything to do
with it you know and it's not a like a
lot of his family members and friends
know like oh they just didn't think that
he was responsible to X he was a
criminal he had been convicted of other
things but they just didn't see him as
being responsible for these kind of
vicious crimes now of the 11 official
official strangling victims six of them
were between the ages of 55 and 75 now
there were two more like sort of victims
which might have been part of the series
as well one of them was 69 and one of
them was 85 but then there were five
more that were young you know girls that
were from 19 to 23 years old now the
first victim the first series was
actually a 55 year old woman her name
was anise lessers and she was divorced
she had actually she was originally from
Latvia but she had actually like fled
there I guess she ran away from her
husband or went ran away from political
strife in the country or whatever she
had taken off with her son and daughter
and came and lived in Boston in the Back
Bay Area she was a seamstress and she
lived like in a really tiny apartment so
apparently on the evening of June 14th
1962 she was going to go to these
memorial services at her church and her
son whose name was juris or URIs he was
supposed to come and pick her up so
while she was kind of getting ready to
do that she was getting ready to take a
bath or whatever and apparently the
strangler came knocking at her door so
later on that evening when her son came
to her apartment to pick her up for the
memorial services
he starts not
the doors she doesn't answer and he
starts getting really nervous because he
thinks well maybe she fell it's like
maybe she had a heart attack or
something like that so he busts open the
door and he goes in the apartment and
finds her lying in the bathroom with the
cord of like the or the belt of her
bathrobe like tied around her neck
really tightly and it was like left in a
bow
like someone had tied it in a bow hmm
now at first he did not his mind didn't
immediately jump to murder he thought
that maybe she had committed suicide and
that was what he reported to the police
when he called because I guess he told
the police that she had been that he had
talked to her on the phone the night
before and she'd been like depressed or
whatever so that was the first thing
that I did tied abode yeah which I
thought was very odd but but I'm like
maybe he didn't see that because you
know what I mean like maybe he just
supposed to be in there might be you
might be able to kill yourself doing
that ya know I'm kind of curious yeah I
guess if you had the discipline to just
sit there and allow yourself and allow
yourself to not just you know lose
consciousness from lack of blood flow
yeah I don't know that's very strange
but like I said I'm not sure how much of
the scene he saw he just kind of walked
in saw her lying nude like on the
bathroom floor and just assumed you know
what I mean because I think it was in
his mind already that maybe you know she
had sounded bummed out on the phone the
night before it's like oh maybe she
killed herself
so when the police came as I said they
found her lying like really awkwardly
like on the bathroom floor she was still
wearing like her housecoat or her robe
or whatever but it had been um like kind
of opened up you know what I mean so
it's like her shoulders were covered but
she was completely naked from you know
from there down
she had like her left leg was like
stretched out toward the door and then
the other one was like it was like way
over here like almost like somebody's
like spread them you know what I mean
yeah and as I said the you know the
thing from her the belt from her robe
had been tied around her neck like
really really tightly like one
documentary that I saw said it was so
tight that blood was coming out of her
ears you know what I mean um and they
had tied it in a bow like very
deliberately like almost like they were
trying to be too
about it or something now one
interesting thing even though there was
no sign of forced entry it looked like
whoever had killed her had wanted it to
look like it was a robbery because her
purse had been dumped out and like all
of the stuff that was in her purse was
kind of like spread on the floor there
was like a garbage can in the kitchen
that had been rummaged through and like
some of the trash was thrown out a bunch
of drawers were left open and there you
know the stuff that was in him was kind
of moved around or taken out or whatever
there was like it's so there was all
that kind of stuff going on but then
police noticed that there was a bunch of
expensive [ __ ] still in the apartment
like she had this really nice gold watch
you know there was like jewelry and some
of the drawers that was clearly very
expensive and that had not been taken so
like I said looked like it had been
staged like to look like a robbery
because it didn't appear that anything
of note was missing or anything
expensive was missing upon closer
examination they also noted that she had
been sexually assaulted with an unknown
object some and I'm not sure if it was
this case or one of the later ones but
it's like one documentary I saw said it
might have been a wine bottle you know
and this was kind of like a hallmark of
several of the early crimes
now police at this point they speculated
that well maybe this [ __ ] started out as
a burglary but then when you know this
woman came out in a robe or whatever
because she was going to take a bath
like sudden some kind of frenzy like
overtook the guy and like he just
couldn't resist it or whatever so that
was kind of the assumption that they
were going on yeah it sounds like they
didn't have a whole lot of damn
law-enforcement training in terms of
yeah you know what's the early 1960s
yeah they they couldn't recognize a
serial killer or know like I said you
know this was just the first one in the
series and it and this was you know an
unusual unusual in the sense that the
victim was older um you know and it
didn't look like anyone had broken in it
just kind of looked like yeah this this
whole concept though just like some kind
of norm
random guys seeing the woman and just it
overtakes and he can't resist it that
doesn't happen that kind of makes me
worry about like the cops that came up
with that cockamamie figure yeah it's
like is that something you would do or
hey you know what I mean like the cop
they came up with that yeah not in the
Western culture yeah like that seems
like a very odd yeah I don't know I mean
I mean you would think that if you
thought that then you would like jump to
the next logical thing which is like
well this is a crazy person
probably a crazy person would it be like
that right you know I mean yeah so a
couple of weeks after that on June 30th
1962 the next victim was murdered she
was 68 years old
and her name was nina nichols and she
was also murdered in her apartment in
the brighton area of boston same as in
the first case her apartment appeared as
though it had been burglarized all the
drawers were open there was a bunch of
her stuff was like thrown around on the
floor but again there was stuff that was
like left in the drawer left in plain
view in the apartment that was expensive
[ __ ] like there was a whole set of
sterling silver just rolling silver
silverware you know just things like
that there was some cash and you know of
really expensive watch on her wrists and
stuff like that and the expensive camera
and none of that stuff had been taken so
again it looked like someone had just
come in and killed her and then tried to
make it look like a burglary for
whatever reason now just as in the first
case
Nina Nichols was found with her legs
like kind of grotesquely spread out like
very far spread out her robe and slip
to her waist the killer had taken two of
her nylon stockings and put them around
her neck very tightly again so so
tightly that her ears were bleeding and
had again tied them in a very deliberate
bow she had also been sexually assaulted
but not you know not raped by a person
but rapes with an object new again
probably a bottle but they're not
entirely certain she had been heated up
well we'll see how that goes big
like I said this sums up with it yeah
this is there's like some weird [ __ ]
going on with this so she was thought to
have been killed at around five o'clock
in the afternoon now the same day that
this happened about 15 miles north of
Boston there's a suburb called Linn and
a woman named Helen Blake was also
killed she they think she was killed
sometime in the morning like between
8:00 and 10:00 a.m. she was 65 years old
she at all she was also divorced and
lived alone she had been strangled again
with one of her pantyhose one of her
nylons and also the killer had taken off
her bra and then had put that around her
neck over the stockings and tied that in
a bow also now she had been also raped
with an object in her vagina and her
anus but there was no no semen no
nothing like that so the first few cases
this is a person like raping these women
with an object rather than because
they're not finding any sperm or any
kind anything like that
she was actually found in her bed lying
face down naked with her legs like way
spread out again her apartment was
ransacked there were a couple of things
missing I guess her family members said
that she had two really expensive
diamond rings that she were on her
fingers then and those were gone so they
assumed that the killer had pulled them
off the killer also tried to get into a
footlocker but couldn't get into it and
there was like a metal like a lock box
or a strongbox or something like that
and he tried to get into that too and
also was unsuccessful but as far as I
know like those two rings were the only
things that anyone could identify as
being stolen from the apartment even
though the whole place looked like it
was ransacked
so at this stage um you know obviously
the police commissioner and everyone is
becoming very upset because clearly this
is a series at this point so you know
they're telling everybody like
particularly older women that lived
alone it's like you know lock your doors
don't open them for anyone you know get
new locks get any dogs it was like a
whole thing where and this kind of you
know kept taking place like over because
this is a pretty short time like where
all these murders happened where they
said they couldn't keep dogs in the
pound
because like every morning like there
would be all these people there like
getting dogs trying to get dogs I think
all those dogs their lives were saved by
this man I know that's kind of [ __ ] up
but it was like you know they would have
been put this year that's terrible to
say but yeah so yeah so again like all
the cops that you know they took a way
out they said no more vacation time
until this [ __ ] is solved they start
looking into like mental patients and
sex offenders and all the stood there
trying to find this [ __ ] person
before he kills anyone else
now they assumed that because the first
series of victims were older women they
assumed that this was someone with a
psychological problem of some kind of
hatred toward their mother that was
trying to get back at their mother
that's kind of what they were assuming
you know so they have like you know they
have the FBI come and they did like a
whole seminar on the [ __ ] so they were
taking this [ __ ] pretty seriously
however they didn't really get all that
far with the investigation even though
to their credit they were trying so then
on August 19th
there's a woman named Ida yurga she was
75 years old and she was a widow and she
was strangled also in her apartment in
Boston's West End again no sign of
forced entry so she had probably let the
killer in voluntarily
they found her lying on her back on the
living room floor they said she was just
wearing like a like a brown nightgown
and it was completely torn open so she
was just like laying there naked there
was a pillow case knotted around her
neck her legs
they had the person had spread them like
four or five feet apart and had propped
her feet up on to individual chairs and
then like put a pillow like under her
butt like if you were good like as if
you were going to the gynecologist mmm
let you know what I mean yeah and the
way that she was posed was so that her
vagina was basically facing the front
door so that would be the first thing
you see when you walked in yeah so
clearly this is a very messed up person
who was deliberately posing the she's
like hey genitalia yeah look at that
like as soon as you walk yeah I heard
this was actually quite common you know
a lot of these serial killers
yeah but they would kind of display the
victims out in positions that were
compromising yeah or humiliating I like
humiliated yeah you know there he was
this for his own enjoyment and then he
says good just left it like that yeah
yeah maybe either way but yeah so that
was like really particularly the detail
about the feet up in the chairs and they
said at the time that was actually not
reported in the media or I was it was
reported later on but at the time it
wasn't reported in the media we now she
had been manually strangled yeah she
they said she had dried blood all over
her head mouth and ears again she had
been sexually assaulted but probably
with an object because they didn't find
any semen at the site the next one why
they think it was postmortem you know
what I don't know if any I ever read
that it was postmortem probably was yeah
he probably ran in here and strangled
him played around with him it's blonde
officer Winslow because he seemed like
he was doing some [ __ ] after they died
like pose and I'm in watch yeah so I
guess that's not too crazy to think that
there are sometimes these guys don't
like to be watched
yeah kill the person so the person is
not there and then they just kind of
have their way with a dead body and then
they don't wanna then they don't want to
admit it yeah because I think even
they're captured they don't want admit
that serial killers are reticent to talk
about being in Necker yeah but they're I
think they own almost all of them are
they seemed a lot of them do seem you
have those tendencies but like you said
it's really weird it's like it seems
weird that like a serial killer would
have liked shame about anything but they
do seem to like not like talking about
that kind enough cuz like look at like
didn't Bundy get yeah bunny would admit
to what he wouldn't admit to it yeah
like even though they knew he did this
[ __ ] but he was almost kind of like oh
well I'll admit that I did all this
other
yeah yeah he did he read whether alive
but then he killed him and then he
continued to mess with me he took the
heads yeah he take the heads home yeah I
raped the heads you know keep them in
the refrigerator and stuff sometimes
yeah yeah Oh Ted Ted Bundy [ __ ] hell
yeah
you can be TK's over there yeah were you
gonna say about well you know how you
know how these guys are you know it was
free they're bottom-feeders you know
although I think yeah I think he was a
necrophile too well like you said a lot
of where you seem to have that tendency
after BTK hung that little girl you know
I mean I've had I think there was semen
on her there was so he was he was he was
he was jerking off to that uh-huh
nasty [ __ ] yeah he probably to have
sex with her but [ __ ] what's it that's
like it doesn't mean that's bad enough
yeah yeah crazy [ __ ] yeah
alright so less than a day after I -
ergo was killed another woman was killed
this woman was a nurse she was 67 years
old and her name was Jane Sullivan
so she was also killed in her apartment
this was in Dorchester she had actually
been killed prior to I - a guy believed
they by the time they found her she had
already been dead for ten days
so she was obviously you know she wasn't
that number victim she was like an
earlier one now interestingly she was
found in a little bit of a different you
know position they actually found her in
the bathtub she was like on her knees
and her feet were like up over the back
of the tub and her head was like under
the faucet yeah however like several of
the other victims she had also been
strangled with her own nylons although
they don't think that she was killed in
the tub where she was found they think
that she was killed in another part of
the apartment cuz there was like blood
on the floor and like various is like in
the kitchen and the bedroom and stuff so
they think that he killed her and then
like put her in there and then posed her
there for whatever reason they were able
to determine that she had been
sexually assaulted but they weren't
really sure with what or when or
anything like that just because it had
been ten days since and she was very
decomposed but they did find a broom in
the apartment that had bloodstains on
the handle so they assumed that she was
probably sexually assaulted with a broom
handle um you know again just like in
the other crimes no sign of forced entry
so she must have left this person in the
apartment was not ransacked although her
purse was found open although it didn't
look like anything had been taken out of
it now there were no more crimes for
three months even though like Everett
the whole city like goes into a panic
obviously because it's you know this is
several crimes and you know it seems
like it could happen to anybody it's not
just like oh it's the prostitutes or
Owen Society these are like respectable
older ladies like just living in normal
apartments and someone's busting in and
raping and strangling them so everyone
was kind of freaking out but like I said
nothing happened for about three months
now the cops were so working diligently
on the case they're like investigate
homeless people like known sex offenders
all this other kind of [ __ ] but nothing
really came out of it but then there was
another crime and it appeared that if
this was the same killer then he had
decided to change his victim profile
because the next crime that occurred
which was on December 5th 1962 the
victim was Sophie Clark now she was a
student at the Carnegie Institute of
Medical Technology and she was young she
was only and I believe she was only 19
or 20 years old um and also she was
african-american now she also did not
live alone she actually had two
roommates although neither of them were
obviously were home at the time that she
was killed she apparently had been in
her apartment by herself writing a
letter and someone had come to the door
and somehow convinced her to let him
inside even though her friends and
family and everything like that said she
was very cautious particularly because
of all the murders that have been taking
place and actually wouldn't even let
friends inside until she had like you
know
determined who they were and [ __ ] like
that so they said this person must have
been really slick to like have got her
to let him inside because normally she
would not so she was found in the living
room of her apartment again her legs
were like spread way out she'd been
strangled by three of her own nylon
stockings which the guy had taken and
tied around her neck very tightly
he had also tied her slit around her
neck now in this case unlike in the
previous ones she had been sexually
assaulted this time probably in the
usual way because they did find semen on
the rug near her body this is the first
time that they have found semen in the
Boston Strangler cases in all the prior
cases the woman had been sexually
assaulted but by an object and not by a
person maybe he's getting more and more
comfortable with it perhaps so so you
know interesting too that he went not
only for a different age group
significantly this was quite a young
woman but also a different racial
profile although this was the only black
victim all the other ones were white but
yeah prior to this they'd all been older
ladies they usually don't go outside
their race but maybe there's just
something about her yes how you'd liked
her it's yeah it would be it's like it
didn't seem like it's just weird because
it seemed like there was this one run of
like the older ladies and there was a
three-month gap and then there was like
a run of like younger women that was
usually like students and stuff like
that so the cops start questioning the
neighbors now there was this one
neighbor named Marcela Luca and she
lived in the same building obviously she
said that in about 220 on the afternoon
of the murder that this guy had knocked
on her door and said that the
superintendent had sent him to see her
about painting her apartment now he she
said that this guy also said that he
said that she had a nice figure and
asked her if she'd ever thought of
modeling Sam now she got creeped out
understandably so she even though no one
was home she put her finger to her lips
and said
you know don't wake my husband up he's
sleeping in the next room at that point
she said the guy got mad and kind of
like took off all right now
interestingly and this is one of the
things among the many other things I'll
get into later that lead people to
believe that maybe Albert DeSalvo
was not the Boston Strangler or at least
was not the only Boston Strangler like I
said I'm not sure if I buy that he
didn't do them all but this is one of
the things that people point to because
this woman said that the guy that came
to her door she said that he was between
25 and 30 years old that he was of
average height that he had honey colored
hair and that he was wearing a dark
jacket and dark green trousers you know
so anybody that knows what Albert
DeSalvo looked like that doesn't really
sound like him but we'll get into that a
little later now you know it's so
there's been speculation there like well
was this the strangler or was it just a
coincidence I mean it does seem weird
they do think that Sophie Clark was
killed at around 2:30 in the afternoon
which was not long from the time when
this guy was like knocking on this other
woman's door so maybe this guy was just
like going around like looking for
victims or whatever and she just
happened to be like ya know and didn't
open the door and then he just went
somewhere else but like I said however
the description of him did not look like
what you know Albert DeSalvo they would
later find out that he looked like now
the next victim was found three weeks
later this was another young woman her
name was Patricia Bessette she was 23
years old she worked at a Boston
engineering firm now her body was
actually found on December 31st 1962 New
Year's Eve
because I guess her boss had come by to
pick her up for work and she didn't
answer the door and then he thought oh
well maybe she got another ride or
whatever and then he went on to work and
then she didn't show up so he went back
to the apartment building and got like
the the superintendent or whatever to
like let her like to let him into the
house like I think they climbed in a
window or so
thing like that now interestingly she
was not found all splayed out like the
other ones were she was actually found
lying in her bed like on her back and
the covers had been like pulled up to
her chin and it just looked like she was
laying there sleeping however when they
pulled the blankets off
she had a whole bunch of stockings like
her nylons and stuff like they were all
knotted together with this blouse and it
had been like really tied like really
tight around her neck she had also been
raped both vaginally and anally
they also found out that she had been
pregnant she was in very early stages of
pregnancy
now her apartment had been searched but
it didn't appear that anything of value
was stolen it's funny because he kind of
ransacked the apartment as if it's a
robbery huh when it's obvious that
that's not what the motive is yeah he's
not getting anything out of this nothing
big yeah I'm like really mystified as to
why there were lot felt I need to do
that yeah there were lock boxes there
probably look for trophies it was weird
you may be just curious maybe he could
find some cash but yeah maybe he was
just not a motive maybe he was just
going through their [ __ ] because he
could yeah you know who they were like
maybe he kind of got off on it yeah so
he didn't really seem to take much of
anything yeah and then like he said in
in the early in in the early in home
invasions he found the lock boxes but he
didn't make a big effort to get in them
yeah it's like it looked like he tried
to get in there but like after a while I
guess yeah it kind of [ __ ] a thief or
you I mean you know you can get into
that kind of stuff if you want to yes I
think he wasn't trying very yeah they
only keep out honest people yeah really
yeah if you have you know this padlock
sir you know the combination locks just
a sliver a damn piece of damn aluminum
can bit built the bent the right way and
you can go down the inside and open them
up you know around we know that a little
the little u-shaped part of it that goes
down inside the padlock yeah you can
take a little round piece of
of what you could just take a little
piece of aluminum can and if you wrap it
around there you can actually kind of
poke it down in there and it'll open
yeah if you Jimmy it with it long enough
and a hammer will shock open most of
that [ __ ] anyway yeah it makes noise I
just think it's like he didn't give a
[ __ ] about getting well yeah I always
feel like it was there was like a
ritualistic component to it because it
seemed like boy like one if you break
into someone's apartment well he didn't
break in he just got in someone's
apartment and you can you rape and kill
them like why would you spend like extra
time just like going through all their
[ __ ] if you weren't gonna take anything
you know what I mean it just seems like
a waste of time so it almost seems like
he was doing it it was just like part of
the time part of being in there yeah
yeah I kind of suspect that that might
have been why weird
yeah just very very weird so now though
okay now the next victim happened two
months later now this was uh Beverly
salmon's oh actually no there was one
before that although they're not sure if
it was one of the official ones this
actually have it in early March of 1963
but this happened 25 miles away from
Boston in Lawrence and this was another
older woman this one was named Mary
Brown and she was 68 years old now she
was actually found beaten to death in
her apartment but she had also been
raped and strangled although it wasn't
the strangling that had killed her it
was the beating so as I said that seemed
like a kind of a throwback to the other
ones so they are kind of like relating
it to that but you know I mean that's I
don't know if they consider that one of
the official ones it may be so now this
was the one that I was starting to talk
about so back in Boston in May of 1963 a
woman named Beverly Salmons who was 23
years old she was a graduate student she
actually she had been supposed to go to
like choir practice or something like
that and I guess her friend you know she
didn't show up so her friend who had a
key to her apartment like got worried
about her and he went and opened her
apartment up to see where she was and
the minute he opened the front door he
sees her laying all splayed out on the
so
a bed in the living room now her hands
had been tied behind her with a scarf a
nylon stocking and two handkerchiefs
were like all tied together and tied and
knotted around her neck in a boat there
was a cloth over her mouth and
underneath that there was like another
cloth that had been stuffed inside her
mouth now this one was odd too because
it looked like the person had attempted
to strangle her but that wasn't what
killed her what actually killed her was
four stab wounds in her neck
there were also 18 stab wounds in her
left breast that were in like a
bull's-eye Denine now this is the only
one that had this particular detail yes
so the stuff that was around her neck
they they called it as [ __ ] up but
like in the police report I guess they
called it decorative because that wasn't
what had killed her the stab wounds had
killed her hmm
um now she had not been sexually
assaulted either by a person or by an
object by the time they found her they
thought that she had probably been dead
from 48 to 72 hours now police at the
time speculated that because she was
actually studying to be an opera singer
that maybe when the person like maybe
she had like really strong throat
muscles so like when the killer tried to
strangle her it wasn't really working so
he got frustrated and started stabbing
her instead that was the only thing they
could come up with does sound right to
me but yeah but they're saying they
they're assuming that this is the same
person even though this is the only one
that had stabbing even though they did
try to strangle her in the you know the
ligature around the neck was similar so
the ones things in the other cases even
though that wasn't what how she was
killed now at this point this is a whole
bunch of murders piling up and obviously
the Boston Police and you know it you
know the cities and the other
jurisdictions like where the victims
were we're kind of getting a lot of [ __ ]
like from the media and from the public
and everything like that because you
know a lot of pressure on them to like
solve this case four more people got
killed so they're getting a little
desperate
so they decide to call in a second
now this psychic whose name is Paul
Gordon
he said that he had a vision of the man
who had killed the first victim anise
lasers and he described the killer as a
tall man with bony hands pale white skin
red bony knuckles and hollow set eyes he
said that he had like a little curl of
hair that he kept like pushing back off
his forehead all the time
said he had a tooth missing in the upper
right front of his mouth now an
interesting thing that he said was he
said that he's in a hospital or some
kind of home like a psychiatric hospital
but it's not he's not confined there all
the time because in my vision I see him
like walking around like in the yard and
everything like that so he's not like
locked up um
now another interesting thing that he
said about this alleged killer was that
he said okay this guy used to beat up
his mother a lot um he's and he like
sleeps and basements and like wanders
around the street like watching women
his mother's dead but he's always like
looking for her and maybe that's why
he's like killing these older women now
so as I said since the police were
taking this fairly seriously and the guy
seemed to have like a pretty good
breakdown of this guy's you know
appearance so they started showing him
like a whole bunch of photos now the one
photo that this guy picked was this dude
named Arnold Wallace now he looked
pretty much exactly like this dude had
described now Wallace was a patient at
Boston State Hospital he was 26 years
old and just like the psychic had said
he had ground privileges like he was a
patient there but he was allowed to walk
around like fairly freely just like the
psychic said he actually kind of
wandered off the grounds every now and
then slept in cellars he had all he was
also known to have beaten his mother in
the past so they talked to the psychic
more and they said that another weird
thing was that the psychic seemed to
describe the apartment of Sophie Clark
you know the african-american woman that
had been killed described it almost
exactly
however he said that this woman was not
a victim of the Boston Strangler that
she had actually been killed by a man
that she knew and he described who he
thought the perpetrator of that crime
was and he he said it was like a big
like a big burly black guy that um that
sophie had known now the police were
kind of freaked out by this because they
said you know there was a suspect in her
murder named Lewis Barnett who looked
exactly like the psychic had said and he
and he did know her like I guess they
had dated once or twice in the past and
so he had kind of come up on the radar
or someone else now when the cops went
to check out Arnold Wallace the guy that
the psychic had described as the
strangler they found out that weirdly
and coincidentally that the times when
he had like disappeared from the
hospital grounds matched up exactly to
when the strangler murders had a cleared
so that was a little bit creepy so then
they take the psychic to the hospital
and her like you know point him out to
us and he's and he said yeah that's him
like that's the strangler
so so the cops were you kind of like
would this psychic [ __ ] doze ever like
he's a real psychic and everything like
that however they start talking to our
Wallace who had actually at a very low
IQ so it was kind of like hard to
interview him because you know yeah you
know he wasn't real the brightest bulb
on the tree and they couldn't really
figure out like where he was coming from
or if he had anything to do with it
because you know he was just so
difficult to communicate with and then
later on even though the cops did kind
of like lend some credence to this they
did find out that the psychic had
actually been to that hospital before
and that he had actually seen Arnold
Wallace before like walking around the
grounds and also he had kind of been
talking to the police and there was some
speculation that the police had like fed
him some information right so yeah yeah
and [ __ ] like a hoax T so yeah they
never did it and they
did also look into the possibility that
maybe the psychic was the strangler and
the world was like trying to like fob it
off on someone else you know what I mean
which actually would be a pretty smart
thing to do if you were the actual
killer yeah what's the chances though
sure you're gonna kill her in it
and you're the psychic yeah although
like I said if you were the killer it's
like it seems you should go to the
police and just say oh I'm actually a
psych yeah it's like this other person
you know maybe are like I'm saying
you're trying to like fob it off on
someone else well a lot of those guys on
the search teams do that kind of [ __ ]
yeah well that's very common throughout
their search and for searching for the
murderer yeah that happens a lot on the
search team which and I think any cops
know that now yeah so it's like now
that's why they go to funerals and they
like check out like all the people that
are like in the search because they know
that like killers just they can't resist
doing that kind of [ __ ] like a lot of us
so the summer of 1963 goes by with no
more murders however there was another
one on September 8th 1963 and this one
happened in Salem now this woman's name
was Evelyn Corbin and she was 58 years
old she was actually strangled with two
of her nylon stockings she lay face up
on her bed nude her underwear had been
stuffed into her mouth they're also
found like around the bed they found
like all these um tissues that had like
lipstick on them and they also had semen
on them they did actually find semen in
her mouth but not in her vagina right so
again know what happened now yeah
so again her apartment looked as though
it was searched but nothing looked like
it was taken like they like the killer
took there was like a tray of jewelry
like cuz you know older ladies like used
to keep their jewelry on trays or
whatever um he just like took it out of
where it was and just like left it on
the floor but like didn't throw anything
out or litter and you just kind of put
it there right um you know and dumped he
dumped her purse out onto the sofa but
nothing was like found they also found
this one really weird kind of clue it's
like right outside the window like on
the fire escape
they found a doughnut like I don't know
if it had a bite taken out
I don't think so I think it was just
like African donut just like left there
which they thought was right and
anything do this so maybe it not maybe
not but they're like they could you
figure out why there was this donut like
sitting outside the window it's just
very weird
probably out there for the birds yeah
maybe an avert it maybe it was stale or
something yeah and the birds didn't show
up so my god yeah so so again since this
is 1963 obviously in November of that
year JFK was assassinated now this is
kind of sad because right around the
same time that JFK was assassinated
there was another Boston Strangler
murder and this woman probably she
probably got relegated to like page
[ __ ] 20 or something like that of the
newspaper just because they found her
body like a few days after the president
got right like that's [ __ ] them so her
name was Joanne Graff she was 23 eight
years old she was actually killed in her
apartment in Lawrence again she had been
strangled with two nylon stockings tied
in a very elaborate bow around her neck
there were also teeth marks on one of
her breasts the outside of her vagina
was found like all cut up and bloody now
when the police interviewed her
neighbors there was a student that lived
at the apartment above her like at the
floor above her and this person said
that at 3:25 in the afternoon he had
heard footsteps in the hallway outside
of his apartment so his wife was like
won't you like peek out there and see
who that is because like I said all
these murders have been taking place so
everyone's a little on edge so he's like
you know it sounds like somebody's kind
of sneaking around out there so why
don't you check it out and see what it
is so this guy goes out and he hears
somebody knocking on the door of the
apartment across from theirs so he kind
of like opens the door and peeks out and
he sees a guy who's about 27 years old
he has like that hair would like pomade
in it or whatever and he's wearing like
kind of these dark green slacks and a
dark shirt and jacket now he asks the
person he says does Joan Graff live here
now her name was Joanne but you know it
was Joan Joanne so
was like that was messed up now the
student and the other apartment said no
she lives you know on the floor above me
now then the guy said so then he's like
I heard the guy going up to the floor
and then I heard a door open and closed
so I assumed that this guy knew Joanne
and went up there and she let him in you
know what I mean and didn't think any
more about it
no it must have been like sometime about
that because right around you know cuz
he said he saw this person around 325
3:30 in the afternoon now 10 minutes
after that like another friend of
Joanne's had called the apartment and
there hadn't been an answer so obviously
the killer had been in there at that
point and no one had answered the phone
now another woman that lived in the same
apartment building she said that the day
before Joanne was murdered this woman
also heard somebody sneaking around out
in the hall way like walking around on
the hallway
then she saw like a piece of paper like
it looked like someone was sticking a
piece of paper under the door and like
moving it around and then she looked at
it like what the [ __ ] and then like it
was kind of snatched away and then she
heard footsteps like going down the hall
yeah so I don't know if this was the
same person or if that's that was just a
coincidence but we achieved if that's
true that was the day before Joanne was
killed so was he like casing the joint
like for a few days beforehand or what
that just seems really weird so that
might have been unrelated I'm not really
sure but that was something else that
like then a neighbor reported so the
next murder took place in January very
early January in 1964 this was 19 year
old Mary Sullivan now she lived with two
of her roommates but again neither of
them were home at the time of her murder
her roommates both came home and found
her murdered in the apartment she had
actually been strangled with a stocking
and then with a silk scarf which had
been tied and like this big huge bow and
then there was another scarf on top of
that kind of a grotesque thing was that
whoever had killed her had taken like it
was like a Happy New Year's card and had
like either leaned
it against her feet so like you would
see it when he came in or I've also
heard say like that they put it between
her toes um I think they like leaned it
against the bottoms of her feet she was
apparently found she was sitting up on
her bed with her back like up against
the headboard they said there was like a
thick liquid which they assumed was
semen dripping out of her mouth and they
found a broomstick handle rammed
three-and-a-half inches into her vagina
it was just rammed in there and broken
off and left so special
now at this point again you know cops
are kind of getting a lot of [ __ ] from
the media and the public and everything
like that so they decide that they're
going to have to form like a super
special task force you know because at
this point they're having to take people
off of other cases and you know people
are getting moved around everything they
said we want a specific tax task force
where you're just working on that you
guys are just working on this and
nothing else and you can't be worked up
you know you can't be pulled off to life
work on anything else so that's kind of
like when they got this whole thing
together and tried to get their [ __ ]
together at this point yes they know
they're dealing with dealing with a
serial killer even though like I said
and we've discussed this before it's the
1960s they didn't really call it that
yet they didn't really they didn't
really have the phrase serial killer
until the 1970s but they did know that
this was probably the same perpetrator
although like I said there was some some
of the experts thought that that it
might have been two different killers
like one killer that did like the older
women and then another killer that did
the younger ones even though some of the
modus operandi for both of the crimes
was similar enough that it could have
all been the same ones they were just
kind of questioning because the victim
profile was so different well did they
all stop at the same time or the murders
just keep on going no they all stopped
yeah it's him probably I kind of am
leaning toward that too it's like yeah
we're to a moral it's unusual for serial
killers to target to different
populations or to different kinds of
victims but I in this case I don't think
they were different enough to warrant
saying that it was two different killers
you know what I mean yeah I'm
it's like yeah there were older ladies
and then there were younger women but I
was just kind of like yeah they're all
women yeah maybe he didn't care and they
pretty much all lived alone and it's
like the same maybe he didn't
discriminate between age they just had
to be an opportune target that's kind of
what I'm wearing he didn't care if they
were young or old you just gotta both
yeah and probably something that he said
later on like leads me to believe that
that is probably the case right so we're
probably yeah we're like right at the
halfway point now so I think I'm going
to take a break at the moment and then
when we come back we will talk some more
about the Boston Strangler case and all
of the different fun things that Albert
DeSalvo got up to you before and after
he allegedly committed these murders
because he was that he was a bad boy all
right
other otherwise so he will be back in
just a few minutes
you love true crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume three is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
baby's case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain volume three is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
you know Pookie in the ball yeah you in
the bowl I'm sorry I'm bothering you
she word at me that's how she talks
she's like go away please all right I'll
go away I'm sorry all right we're back
talking about the Boston Strangler case
yeah now when we last left I was talking
about the strangler Bureau the task
force that had been formed to
investigate to the strangler murders now
okay so at this point like I said
there's a $10,000 reward for any
information for catching this guy [ __ ]
like that now the task force they
actually one of their jobs was to kind
of like consolidate all of the [ __ ]
because a lot of these crimes that
happened in like different jurisdictions
you know not all of them happened in
Boston Proper so they had to kind of
like footsy they have like thumbed it
something like 37,000 40,000 like pages
of [ __ ] that they kind of from all these
different jurisdictions that they had to
put together and everything like that
now they also had a forensic medical
team and these guys were doing
essentially what today we would call
profiling even though they didn't call
it that at the time so that was one of
their jobs they said you know what kind
of dude are we looking for for this
killer now it was this team's opinion
and I kind of alluded to this earlier
that the to Cirie the two sets of crimes
the older women and the younger women
they thought had been committed by two
different people they thought that the
older women that had happened earlier
that that was one guy and then the other
ones were a copycat they didn't think
that there were enough similarities to
justify being thinking that it was the
same person now when they asked them to
kind of submit a report it's like what
type of dude are we looking for they
thought that this was going to be
somebody that was at least 30 years old
probably older than that they thought
this was somebody that was like a very
controller and a person a very neat very
orderly very punctual
they thought it was someone who worked
with their hands or had a hobby like
that like you know woodworking or
something of that nature they thought
this that was gonna be a single guy or a
separated or divorced guy someone that
didn't seem crazy some of it seemed
fairly normal and wouldn't strike an
average person as unusual someone with
no close friends of either sex that's
what was in their report this is the guy
that they thought that they would be
looking for now since they didn't really
have a lot more leads at this point the
task force again decides to bring in a
psychic now this guy is apparently he's
quite famous I'd heard the guy's name
before he's Dutch his name is Peter
hurkos so they brought this guy in and
asked him to kind of give his input on
the case now he actually did come up
with this particular suspect and the
suspect that he came up with was a guy
that the that the bureau had been
looking at this guy although I don't
know what his name is I don't believe he
was ever named but he worked as a shoe
salesman and he had a history of mental
illness the police did investigate this
guy but couldn't find any physical
evidence to tie him to any of the cases
and at any rate the guy ended up
voluntarily committing himself to a
mental hospital at some point anyway so
I guess it was a moot point even if he
was the strangler which I doubt um how
Peter hurkos the psychic actually got in
a little bit of trouble later for
allegedly impersonating an FBI agent so
that kind of so sadly the the strangler
task force was looked at a little
askance by people because they're hiring
these psychics and these psychics are
doing all this kind of stuff now
interestingly nowadays even though when
you say Boston Strangler most people
jump to Albert DeSalvo because he
confessed to all of them Albert DeSalvo
I don't believe was ever actually a
suspect in the Boston Strangler murders
even though if you looked into his
criminal history he definitely should
have been on someone's radar in
hindsight you know what I mean because a
lot of crimes he committed were not as
bad but similar you know similar like
wheel out Hallman
vision peeping-tom type shape so it's
very surprising to me that he wasn't you
know on anyone's radar at the time it
wasn't until later on that people looked
back as other crimes that were like Oh
hobbies a lot of serial killers from
this era and even beyond into the 70s
start off as peeping toms I don't know
that but a lot of the FBI got into that
a lot of them start off as peeping toms
and then they decide well instead of
looking in there I'm gonna go I'm gonna
go in there yeah yeah that's usually
Howard yeah it's an escalation yeah it's
an escalation but yeah I did yeah I do
think that they I mean I think they've
kind of got that sorted out now but I
think like I said back back in the early
mid 1960s this you know the serial
killer profiling that whole thing was
very much in its infancy and I don't
know I mean it seems like they did what
they could in this case because they did
have like guys come in a profile they
did like have all that kind of [ __ ] but
you know some of the ideas they had
about who this guy probably was we're a
little bit off yeah you know so it so
happened that a couple of years before
the Boston Strangler murders began there
were a bunch of these really weird kind
of they're not exactly sexual assaults
but the get in there it's in that area
these all took place in the kam bridge
area what would happen was there was
this guy and he was in his late 20s he
would knock on the door of a random
apartment apparently if a young woman
answered the door he would he would give
them a spiel something to the effect of
he would tell them his name was Johnson
he would say he worked for a modeling
agency
and he would tell the woman he's like oh
someone gave us your name they thought
you would make a good model yeah then
he's like this isn't nude modeling it's
nothing like that it's just evening
gowns and swimsuits and everything and
he was said that it would pay $40 an
hour he said I have been sent here to
get your measurements and other
information about you to see if you were
interested in doing any modeling now he
would canvass down the whole street or
he just did that to I guess
I'm not really sure cuz boy they call
the cops on you quick I'm saying so well
yeah later on like it happened and well
like I said this was you know late 50s
early 60s so maybe people were kind of
more naive now if you try to pull this
nowadays you'd probably get your face
shot off especially especially if you
have one let's just say we have modest
women yeah I'm talking about they're
like yeah [ __ ] yeah that's you know
a lot of women you know when they're
being bullshitted they know when they
don't look good really considering the
things you is that any what models look
like like if some strange dude knocks on
the door I'm not opening the door I'm
not yet a chance to say anything yeah
the [ __ ] you don't know who you are some
people told us that you would make a
good model make it the [ __ ] think about
that well yeah I'd be like well
obviously they look at me like [ __ ]
80 pounds overweight go I don't know did
a blind person tell you yeah yeah but
yeah um well I guess he only pulled this
like I said he went around knocking at
random doors and I guess like if like an
old person answered or an ugly person or
a man or whatever he would probably just
say Oh wrong house and you know we just
moved then this I'm assuming you know I
don't know I'm not him but I'm saying so
now apparently this was successful a few
times now he would tell the measuring
them you know I mean like taking their
measurements yeah and then he would tell
them now apparently like some
documentaries that I saw later they said
oh well sometimes he'd have sex with
them but like willingly yeah and then
sometimes he would rape them but I'm not
super sure about that is he had his way
of talking his way you know yeah and
then good get it and I think that that's
done like the more I know about Albert
DeSalvo he did seem like um as funny
looking as he was a lot of his friends
and family and stuff like that said he
was real charming and real personable
and he apparently didn't have much
trouble you know getting women like he
can talk his way up skirts yeah but it
wasn't violent he want he liked violence
right so um so I do feel like the fat
that I mean he had to have had some kind
of charisma or something like that to
have gotten so many people to let him
into they like the willing and unwilling
evidently yeah it really does seem yeah
so yeah so apparently a large number of
women actually did kind of let him
inside at least like to measure them
maybe if it got weird they kicked him
out and [ __ ] like that then he would
tell them oh it's like there's this lady
mrs. Lewis she's from the agency and
she'll be calling you if your
measurements are okay or whatever and
then obviously no one named mrs. Lewis
would ever call because I'm she didn't
exist and the more of this had started
to happen like some women actually did
contact the police because they thought
this was like weird and sketchy now in
March of 1961 the cameras police caught
a guy who was trying to break into a
house now not only did he you know
confess to breaking and entering into
this particular house which they had
kind of caught him red-handed he also
confessed to being what the media had
started to call the measuring man he
wouldn't come to your door and say can I
take you imagine but that's what they
started to call him yeah so he said yeah
that's me
now this turned out to be Albert DeSalvo
unsurprisingly at the time he was 29
years old and had had numerous prior
arrests mainly for breaking and entering
and stealing you know he would steal
whatever money he found in the apartment
he actually had he lived in Malden he
had a wife who was German
and he had two small children he had a
day job he was a press operator in a
rubber factory so they asked him like
what the [ __ ] man I'm sure they didn't
use this word right but they're like
what was this all about like it like I
said I've seen like different things
because some of them said oh he raped
the women and stuff like that but most
of the stuff I think he just wanted
their measured them and that said Oh
some will be calling you and then she
left and then he left which to me like
seems really weird so that was kind of
chasing him out yeah so the cops asked
him it's like what the [ __ ] is the deal
with that and he said and apparently
this is a direct quote he said I'm not
good-looking I'm not educated but I was
able to put something over on
class people yeah they were all college
kids and I never had anything in my life
and I outsmarted them so apparently that
was the only reason he was doing it so I
don't know I don't think so no but
that's what he said anyway case now
future victims as he might have been
yeah and like I said this might have
been and this definitely does seem like
a case of because this was a couple of
years before the Boston Strangler
murders so this definitely does seem
like he's like ratcheting up because
like I said I'm gonna tell you right now
I really do think that Alberta Salva did
commit all these crimes or at least the
vast majority of them you know I mean I
know there's like some thing about some
people think he didn't do all of them or
whatever I kind of suspect that he maybe
did so um most of them at least most of
them yeah right so he goes before a
judge now the judge is like oh you know
he's got a family he's got two small
children so let's go lenient on him so
he only got 18 months now he was
released from jail in April of 1962
which coincidentally or maybe not was
only two months before the first victim
of the strangler was murdered now let's
talk a little bit about Albert DeSalvo
'he's past and his childhood and stuff
like that so he was born in 1931 in
Chelsea Massachusetts kind of like a
real poor like working-class
neighborhood he actually I think he had
five siblings as in the case of many
serial killers or alleged serial killers
in this case his dad was a drunk and
also a violent very violent person
apparently and both he and several of
his siblings told this story as well but
apparently their dad once broke all of
their mom's fingers by bending them all
backwards until they broke right in
front of all of them damn Albert DeSalvo
Albert DeSalvo 's brother also said that
the dad had always had once like picked
Albert up by the neck like when he was
very small and like trying to strangle
him and stuff so it wasn't a happy
household I mean the kids were all
getting beat up the wife was getting
beat up or whatever the dad's name is
Frank by the way
now even though like Albert's teachers
and stuff like that thought that he was
you know a real friendly kid and and all
of that but he got into like delinquency
at a pretty young age apparently his dad
was kind of a criminal also and kind of
taught him things some documentaries I
saw said that he kind of taught him like
breaking it in or in techniques and [ __ ]
like that which that's a pretty [ __ ]
up father-and-son time
regular father and sons go fishing we're
gonna go like figure out a walk and like
break into some [ __ ] but apparently that
was some [ __ ] that was going on so he
actually the first time he was arrested
was when he was 12 years old that was in
1943 mostly breaking and entering
assault and battery that type of stuff
so in December of 1943 he was actually
sent to one of those both one of those
boy schools like a reform school the
Lyman school for boys which you know
apparently that wasn't a super great
place either because you know it's a
bunch of delinquent kids so that was
also very violent so not much better
than his home life in October of 1944 he
got paroled out of there and he got a
job as a delivery boy but he still kept
getting in trouble with the like up
stealing cars [ __ ] like that so he got
sent back to the school you know as
subsequently either his father died or
his mom like kicked him out or whatever
the mom remarried she tried to kind of
like keep Albert on the straight and
narrow apparently they had a pretty
decent relationship him and his mom
there wasn't didn't seem to be like a
lot of hostility there or anything like
that and for it seemed like he would do
okay for a little while but then like he
couldn't help himself like he would just
fall back into criminality like I said
breaking and entering was was mainly his
thing but he also like got into fights
and [ __ ] like that so he finally he gets
out of the live in school for boys and
he joins the army now he had one tour of
duty he actually I think he was the he
was stationed in Germany for a while he
was a military police sergeant he was so
he was in the Army for I believe eight
years yeah 1948 through 1956
um and actually for a time like I said
he was stationed in Germany and that's
where he met his wife whose name was
irmgard beck now he was actually ended
up being honorably discharged even
though he did actually get in trouble
for I guess some insubordination or like
not a blame obeying orders or anything
like that but I guess you yeah so I
guess it wasn't a big enough deal so he
did actually get honorably discharged
and him and his wife like moved back to
the United States now in 1955 and this
is like a little bit of a hint of where
his little future is going in 1955 he
got arrested for sexually assaulting a
nine-year-old girl now he was actually
might have been going to trial for this
but apparently according to some sources
that I saw you know it kind of like went
on toward the trial and then the girl's
mother decided that she didn't want the
little girl to have to testify because
she thought it would be too traumatic or
too horrible for her so they actually
ended up dropping the charges so that's
again an alleged kind of thing because
he actually was you know accused of it
but they never it never actually went to
trial because the charges were dropped
and I probably happened I'm sure like
like I said in one of the late
leadership um this was the same year
that his first he sounds like what he
did he sounds like a damn sex addict
that's it's funny you should say that
because that is exactly what he was yeah
and that is something that a lot of
people said about him yeah all the
psychiatrist people who'd knew him like
people in his family everything that
said that he was that he would like
masturbate like several times a day yeah
and that he would like just go around
just like bangin chicks like all the
time they shouldn't like even when he
was in the army and stuff like that like
he had a reputation for it right
like he said that he couldn't like help
himself like he had to have it like many
many many times a day or he started
getting like this weird feeling or
whatever yeah yeah yeah he did like it
had this kind of problem yeah and his
wife didn't know about it so 1955 was
also the year that his first child was
born now this was a little girl named
Judy now she had some kind of congenital
disease I guess like some kind of deep
Meishan of her pelvis or whatever and
apparently this was kind of like a big
thing she'll because she was essentially
handicapped now his wife irmgard um
apparently I guess because the kid was
handicapped and she was the one that you
know had to look after her so according
to some sources I read she didn't want
to have sex with him anymore because she
was afraid that she would have another
baby that would have a similar right
handicap she blamed him or herself - um
I don't think she was blaming anyone it
was just kind of like a practical
concern it's like I really don't want to
have another baby right because it might
have a problem say you know and she had
enough to deal with with the one I guess
so apparently um I you know so I guess
she kind of like was like yeah I don't
want to have sex anymore because I don't
want to get pregnant again he's like
okay well [ __ ] that I'm a gland gets off
and yes so essentially that seems like
what happened because his wife seemed to
know like I don't think she was okay
with it but I think she knew the
situation um
you know and one documentary I saw and
I'm not sure how accurate this is but
like one of his family members was like
oh she used to like withhold sex for him
to get what she wanted and [ __ ] like
that but it didn't mention anything
about the handicapped daughter which I
thought was very odd but apparently they
did ended up having sex a few more times
because they did have another kid like
this she did have another kid they had a
son and he was normal so between 1956
and 1960 he was arrested a bunch of
times
mostly for breaking and entering but he
also he always got a suspended sentence
but even though like he seemed to be
getting arrested like all the time he
seemed to like keep a steady job and
it's like most of his like co-workers
and stuff like that thought he was a
great dude like pretty much everyone
they talked to you thought he was a
great dude they said he's he's totally
like into his family like he adores his
wife he's always like very sweet to her
and everything and it's like he had kept
this [ __ ] compartmental yeah he was just
he's just like a totally good guys
totally friendly it's like no way dennis
is the same way that's what I mean it's
like no one would suspect it was a
stand-up character he's in a church and
I never respected him and dudes a [ __ ]
serial rapists in yeah so even though
I'm assuming that you know Albert's
co-workers and friends and his wife and
should obviously knew that he was a
petty thief and maybe they thought that
was a drawback but other than that they
thought he was a pretty cool guy I mean
other than pretty much the only thing
that a lot of people said like as one of
his things that they didn't like about
him was that he had a tendency to that
he was like a blowhard that he would
like bragging about everything and he
was like one of those guys and it's like
if you had a story like he always had to
top it yeah yeah yeah yeah so everybody
knows something like that so yeah so
everybody said that he was kind of like
that but other than that pretty much
everyone thought he was a great guy
which okay now interestingly so he gets
in trouble for that for these measuring
man crimes or whatever now in early
November 1964 which is about three years
after he got released from jail on the
other [ __ ] he gets arrested again now if
you're keeping track cuz I'm kind of
jumping around a time 1964 this is more
than a year after the Boston Strangler
murders okay
so Albert DeSalvo gets arrested in
November 1964 for some other sketchy
[ __ ] that he was doing so apparently on
October 27th he had broken into a
woman's apartment I guess her husband
had just left her for work and she was
still in bed because it was like real
early in the morning he gets in her
apartment he puts a knife to her throat
and says don't make a sound or I'll kill
you
then he sticks her underwear in her
mouth he tied her to the bed posts with
her clothes then he just like he didn't
rape her but he just like kind of felt
her up and like kissed her and stuff and
then he asks her how do I get out of the
apartment then he told her to be quiet
for ten minutes then he said he was
sorry and then he left
and let now keep in mind if this is
Albert DeSalvo that I mean they know
that he did this but if he did the
Boston strangler's this was after the
Boston Strangler murders he let her live
yeah and he didn't rape her just like
and it
over a new leaf maybe that's what it's
like maybe he's trying to like oh well I
tried to go cold turkey he's trying to
like ease out of it or something that so
[ __ ] up but that's like that maybe
that's what it is
so he didn't well he wasn't wearing a
mask or nothing so she got like a really
good look at his face right so she gave
to police you know the police did a
sketch of him from her description and
they said now this guy looks just like
the dude that we got for the measuring
man crimes now this guy um you know they
after he had done a few more they
started calling the Green Man because he
had like green pants on like he had like
he looked like he was trying to look
like a maintenance man so he had like a
green like uniform or whatever so they
arrested Albert DeSalvo and they bring
him to the police station and they bring
the woman in and like let her look at
him like her a one-way mirror and she
says yeah that's him
so at this point they released his photo
like over the teletype or whatever and
in Connecticut they're like yeah we had
like a really weird series of crimes
here called the Green Man crimes and
that looks like the guy that we're
looking for for that so they arrest him
for these Green Man crimes which were
all kind of similar to this one now they
arrested him his house they kind of get
a lot of the victims of these crimes to
like come and make sure that he's the
guy they want to put him in a lineup or
whatever now he said the funniest thing
was that he said that he didn't want he
was like really upset that the police
had arrested him at his house because he
was really embarrassed that his wife
would see him in handcuffs
yeah however when they talked to his
wife she was like not shocked at all
right because apparently she knew she
said yeah he's got like a sex addiction
thing and right the fact that he's going
around doing [ __ ] like this I mean I
don't think she didn't think he was a
murderer but like when they said hey
he's been breaking in people's houses
and like tying women up and like feeling
them up while they're tied up and stuff
she's like yeah par for the course she
didn't seem all that shocked about it
yeah she said that he was a sex addict
and that he she said something like a 1
1 1 woman will never be enough and it's
like he's always like I wanna doing that
kind of [ __ ] and yeah and they think
also that he had done for sexual
assaults in different towns in
Connecticut like in a single day
so this is the kind of person that
you're talking about so his wife told
him like I said she wasn't surprised as
she's just like man just tell him
everything
you know just cough it up so he told the
police that not only had he broken into
over 400 different apartments he also
confessed to at least two rapes and
other types of sexual assaults about 300
of them now they're not really sure
because he was kind of like like to sell
for grand eyes and he was kind of a
braggart they said that might be an
exaggeration obviously but you know
there were some that they could match up
with that guy even if there was more in
he account probably he was doing it on a
regular basis for a long time yeah and I
do feel like and the thing about it too
is that if some weirdo if you let some
weirdo into your house against your
better judgment and he didn't do
anything other than taking your
measurements and then leaving you
probably would not report that to the
police nowadays you would but back then
maybe not maybe and and maybe like even
now you'd think well I was stupid enough
to let him in so they might have been
embarrassed and they might have been
embarrassed about it so so he might have
done all of those and like a lot of
women just maybe didn't report it
because I've heard even to this day that
most rapes just aren't reported I don't
think they are we'll just don't talk
about them well the thing is you have to
be I mean from a woman's point of view
particularly if you've you know and I
don't want to put it this way
necessarily but if you are in a
situation where like say you're at a
party and you drink more than you know
you usually would or whatever then if
you get raped at that party I can see
why people would be reluctant to report
it because that's the first thing
they're gonna ask you what what did you
drink where were you dude you know when
like you miss people what were you
wearing when I make this big goal so
they're gonna make this big thing and
they're gonna make it look like it was
your fault even though it's not
vanishing and then you have to take time
out of your [ __ ] day you know your
your work schedule and everything to
keep going in back to the police and
then and then [ __ ] District
Attorney's office in order to build up a
[ __ ] case against this guy and it's
gonna
and then the politics happened because
chances are you know the guy yeah yeah
and the thing is it's like you know
stranger rate we know somebody that that
kind of happened - yes we do
yeah yeah yes we do and they really do
but I don't blame her
yeah because it just would have taken
more time out of her life well and the
thing is it's like stranger we got wheat
she got even with him known in other
ways yeah yeah that's true so that's I
think that was kind of like the best
outcome she could've hoped for her um
but yeah so I mean stranger rapes that's
a different thing if some dude just like
jumps at or like breaks in your
apartment or obviously but the problem
is that a lot of rapes are like say you
go on a date with a guy and like he put
something in your drink or you know you
go a little bit of away with him and
you're like I don't really like you and
stuff and then you try to say no and
then he forces himself on you and [ __ ]
like that so I think a lot of it if you
know a lot of it happens in that kind of
area the dude one we're talking about
the dude she was drunk he was drunk -
she probably wouldn't let this [ __ ]
slide had he not pulled out his phone
and taking a bunch of [ __ ] Petra's
over yeah and shared him yeah all right
that's the mass that's an [ __ ] move
yeah I tried to brag about it yeah
and then well it's like what the [ __ ]
well and and he has a history of other
types of things yeah he's a [ __ ]
skeevy [ __ ] so his name's mud
now he can't go anywhere everybody knows
about that dude now yes so in a way like
I said it was kind of like I mean
obviously nothing was reported to the
authorities but in half - but because of
an underground network of yeah goth
drama yeah now everybody knows about
that [ __ ] yeah but yeah so it's like we
take care of our own well yeah well and
I feel like like I said if I was in a
situation like I've been in a situation
where I was in a party like I knew a
couple people there but there was a lot
of people there I didn't know and like
you know I was pouring my own drinks I
was having a good time I wasn't thinking
about it and it's like you know at one
party I actually fell asleep like in the
living room luckily I you know I knew a
couple of people are there and they
kind of put me in a room and locked me
in there and [ __ ] like that so no one
could do anything but it's like you know
if you're not in that situation if
something bad happens to you you're
gonna it's not only the fact that you're
gonna get raked over by the coals by
everybody and they're gonna make it seem
like it's your fault but you're gonna
feel like it's your fault they're gonna
because women are very we're always like
questioning our perceptions you know so
well maybe it wasn't as bad as I thought
or maybe this and maybe that it sucks
but it's like we that's just how we do
things so it's kind of like you're
always like questioning your own
perception of what happened and maybe it
wasn't as bad as you thought and maybe
you're making a big deal about it and
maybe this and that the other thing and
it's just like we overthink everything
and so like and then you're having it
reinforced by having other people going
yeah you shouldn't have done this and
you shouldn't warm that you shouldn't
have done this other thing so it's like
it comes it becomes this big thing so I
wearing thing is [ __ ] that is very
bad yeah we go to clubs and [ __ ]
parties and [ __ ] you just have women
just [ __ ] dress just straight-up tape
you know I mean they're gonna let you
look think they might even [ __ ] give
you a big hug and [ __ ] you have a man if
I can but you know you can't you can't
start groping no you get kicked out yeah
just gonna get your butt kicked yeah yes
this is why I'm not being cool yeah that
is definitely I can't make a big deal
out of it it is what it is yeah yeah ass
is ass that's just what happens force
yourself into it yeah and I do feel like
everybody should have learned that by
now it's all yes is it really bad it's
like I don't care it's like just ask
yeah well in the other way it's like you
know I'm not a dude so I don't have the
same thing but it's like you know if
some if some dude is like walking down
the street and like speedos or whatever
that doesn't give me the right to go
over yeah like yeah right he probably
wouldn't care but it's just kind of like
you know what I mean it's like I don't
have the rights why the [ __ ] would I do
that it wouldn't even occur to me so
it's like I don't know why it occurs to
guys that like if there's a woman that
like whereas I'm kind of sexy like
though they're allowed to just let go
over and just start pawing on somebody
sees you know so our friends and where
the [ __ ] were you racing these crazy-ass
[ __ ] nightclubs and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
events that we you see your friends and
they might not have all them dead
it's close I guess you could call it
close it's close adjacent yeah yeah it's
well that's what I mean well we're used
to it we don't yeah so I feel like you
know in a way I'm not saying that like
oh the Goss scene the fetish scene and
stuff like that that it might be a
little bit better because I do feel like
people are used to seeing that kind of
thing and they know they don't not a big
deal it's not a big deal and they don't
feel like oh I'm entitled to you know
and if there is somebody like that it
gets around pretty fast you know I mean
like everybody knows about that [ __ ]
like immediately yeah and then they
can't come back they can't come out of
it yeah it's like goth telephone that's
it I mean it happened yeah it's like
we've had like a couple guys like that
did some sketchy [ __ ] like that and it's
like then they kind of weren't allowed
to come back like if they came out again
like everybody would just like glare at
that man yeah and then nobody talked to
him and they were talking to me knows
what you [ __ ] did yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then eventually yeah so eventually
they figured it out and they just like
couldn't come out anymore because of the
shame so yeah I mean that's how we do
things
it's very passive-aggressive yeah it
does work though yeah but yeah so
whether the guy did as many as he said I
don't really know 300 women attacked
maybe around a four-state area it's
possible like I said he might have been
doing that [ __ ] all the time he
allegedly told the police if you knew
the whole story you wouldn't believe it
it'll all come out you'll find out so at
this point they decide that they're
gonna send Albert DeSalvo to the
Bridgewater State Hospital just for
observation they weren't like putting
him in there or anything like that they
didn't at this point and they didn't
think that I don't think he was a
suspect in the Boston Strangler murders
but they wanted to like check him out
see have a psychiatrist look at him and
see what his problem was
now interestingly not long after he got
to the state hospital the Bridgewater
State Hospital there was another guy who
came in who was also an inmate there his
name was George Nasser now this guy had
actually been charged with a very brutal
execution-style murder of a gas station
attendant he was one of those guys like
he
he had a really really high IQ and it
was really good at like manipulating
people so he was that type of like
sociopathic psychopathic type of
character so he gets put into the same
Ward as Albert DeSalvo now they the two
of them started talking now this is
where all this [ __ ] is coming to a head
early March of 1965 Alberta salvers wife
irmgard she gets a phone call from a
lawyer the very famous lawyer f lee
Bailey oh yeah
f lee Bailey tells her some shits about
to come out about Albert I would advise
that you take the children and get the
[ __ ] out of Dodge he's like I will come
out tomorrow and I will help you but in
24 hours the shit's gonna hit the fan
and you don't want to be here when it
does
now once she was in a safe area F lee
Bailey told her your husband has
confessed to being the Boston Strangler
hmm now she hung up on him she didn't
believe it she did believe that he was
going around like raping people and
doing the molesting [ __ ] but she didn't
believe that she just could go that far
well she didn't believe that he was
violent she did I mean because the
Boston Strangler murders were very
violent and they were like left I mean
the the victims were left in like these
horrible like [ __ ] up positions and
stuff you know what I mean he was
getting kinky yeah I mean yeah so it was
her belief that well you know yeah he's
a thief and yeah and he probably did
these you know mala stations and rapes
and stuff but you know if he confessed
to being the strangler he must be just
trying to get money or trying to like
make himself seem like a big deal or
like he's important or something cuz
that was the type of person that he was
so they think maybe she thought she's
like well maybe he knows that he's going
to jail and so she you know see he's
trying to like confess to all these
crimes so like maybe he'll get some kind
of book deal or something like that you
know to take care of the family so
that's kind of what she thought and some
people still kind of think that now but
apparently what it ended up happening
was that the story goes that Albert
DeSalvo was talking to
this other guy this other murderer like
on the same war george nasser and he
confessed to him that he had done all
the strangler murders and F lee Bailey
was George Nasser's lawyer right so
George Nasser told told F lee Bailey and
then actually F lee Bailey got back and
said that he would defend him as well
now because the you know because of the
confession because they asked out you
know they asked Albert DeSalvo it's like
you know G are you saying that you're
the Boston Strangler and he's like yes
and they said did you do some of them
and he said all of them that's what he
said quote unquote
so here's the thing though now according
to I don't know if this is just
according to George Nasser or according
to some other people now he said that
the two of them were talking and he was
saying about you know yeah I did the
strangler murders and [ __ ] like that now
he was saying to George Nasser it's like
oh there's a $10,000 reward for
information like for the conviction of
the Boston Strangler he's like so for
some reason they thought that it was
$10,000 per victim rather ah just ten
thousand dollars altogether so they
thought it was like over a hundred
thousand dollars so I guess Albert was
saying to George it's like hey why don't
you you know take the credit
you know firt coz and say that I'm you
know the killer and like you can help
but everything then we can like split
the money or like I can give it to my
family because at this point he had been
caught for like all the Green Man market
ourselves and he knew that he was
probably not getting out so I guess in a
[ __ ] up way he might have been kind of
trying to like provide for his family
because he knew he wasn't gonna get out
of prison so he and he so he was trying
to like kind of make a deal with Nasser
that we can collect the reward money
even though I'm pretty sure that's not
how that works no I don't I don't take
another convicted felon would be able to
yes it's like whoa maybe but now I don't
think I'm in that circumstances that
they're gonna weasel their way out of it
yeah see I don't think that was there
one there one there by in this guy they
want a lead from the street somebody
there yeah
did it you know that that is what
they're looking for but I don't know
what happened did he get it I don't
think he got the 10,000 did he tell no
no no Albert DeSalvo has confessed to
all 13 of the Boston Strangler murders
now f lee Bailey decides to take him on
as a you know you know this is a defense
attorney but he says here's the thing
he's like I'm gonna go interview him but
we have to make sure because it's they
didn't have any physical evidence to tie
DeSalvo to any of the murders he had not
been a suspect prior to this yes he had
done other things he'd been convicted of
and there was evidence of that but he
had never been on anyone's radar so the
fact that he had just that it was just a
confession a jailhouse confession on top
of that he's like okay well we have to
make pretty double-dog sure that he is
not just like making some [ __ ] up
so f lee Bailey decides that he's gonna
go interview me takes his little
dictaphone or whatever he asked the
police he says give me a list of 25
questions that only the killer would
know so he goes to talk to Albert
DeSalvo and asks him these 25 questions
and apparently he got all of them
correct like down to the detail because
everyone has said that Albert solve it
was like a really good memory he wasn't
like super intelligent or anything like
that but he had like a really good
memory they asked him like little [ __ ]
like you know he would volunteer
information like oh in one of the
apartments like I knocked this one's
like a pack of cigarettes like off the
thing and like it got pushed under the
dresser or whatever and he knew the
brand and he knew where it was and [ __ ]
like that and obviously nobody would
know that except for the cops that took
the picture of the scene and things like
that so yeah so they're kind of like
thinking and f lee Bailey I mean from
the beginning even though he was
defending him once he had confessed he's
like look I know that this is probably
the strangler it's like he's not talking
like someone that's just telling a story
that someone else told him or somebody
that's just like pulling [ __ ] out of his
ass he sounds like he's describing
something that happened to him that he
saw I mean in his opinion that's what he
thought so at one point they're asking
um DeSalvo about like all of the
different crimes like I said they're
trying to get like details because they
didn't have any physical evidence at the
time
so he described like in intricate detail
the one particular crime which was the
murder of Ida agar which happened in
August of 1962 he basically said like
how he got people to let him in he would
he would pose as a maintenance man he
would say oh the superintendent sent me
or I'm supposed to come in and paint
your apartment I'm supposed to measure
it I'm supposed to do something like
that and he's like most of them were
suspicious at the beginning of you know
and in this case particularly she was
very suspicious and didn't want to let
him in and he said what he would do it's
like I kept talking to her and he's like
oh well don't worry it's like if you
don't want me to come in now like I'm
supposed to come in and you know do some
work in the apartment but if you don't
want me to come in it's no skin off my
nose I can come back tomorrow that's
fine and then he started to walk away
and then she said oh you know never mind
it's fine just come on in so apparently
that was something that he was doing
that he was like posing as someone that
was coming in to like work in the
apartment you know for like the landlord
was telling him to come in and even and
he was acting like he didn't care if he
got let in you know what I mean if I go
I can come back tomorrow don't worry
about it or whatever and then most of
the women be like okay we'll go ahead
and come in so he kind of described like
how he got into people's apartments like
I said he knew pretty much the layouts
of all the apartments he knew like
little bitty details about you know the
murders how they had occurred he knew
about the blood coming out of the ears
he knew about the the one victim that
had the feet like up in the chairs make
that like table said and that had not
been published in the media at the time
like what are you saying the chairs he
came out and said um he he got asked
like he's like did you grab this victim
from behind and he said yes I strangled
her manually he said I noted blood
coming out of her ear very dark the
right ear I remember that he's like and
then I think there was the dining room
set in there a really dark one and there
were brown chairs around it and I recall
putting her legs up on her two chairs in
a wide position one leg in each chair
and like I said that had not been
reported in the media do you see why no
that they said that um f lee Bailey
asked him it's like why why did you
first attack such old women yeah and he
said and I believe this is a this is an
exact quote he said attractiveness had
nothing
with it she's a woman that's enough okay
so that's what I mean
so now the one woman that he that he
attacked that was much younger Sophie
Clark the african-american woman she was
22 he actually thought that she was
actually really beautiful like when it
came so I guess he was just like
knocking on doors until he saw somebody
she liked and you know [ __ ] like that
and he had done the modeling ruse on her
he said that he and he described at her
apartment looked like what color her
door was on the inside he's like yeah
she had two roommates they weren't home
at the time I said I was gonna give her
25 to 35 dollars an hour he said about
like a daybed that she had in there what
color the pillars pillows were all that
other kind of stuff so they kind of like
they checked all these details like I
said she knew like really little big
details he said when he went to like
rape Sophie he said oh she was on her
period and he had taken like her you
know sanitary napkin or whatever like
thrown it and they said that was that
was true you know he's like I was
looking for like I said the pack of
cigarettes he's like I knocked a pack of
cigarettes on the floor when I was
looking for a stocking to strangle her
with and he knew what brand it was he
knew where it had been left he knew all
of that kind of stuff so yeah now the
interesting thing about what f lee
Bailey was planning to do with Albert
DeSalvo
defense they're like well since he
already confessed they're like basically
what we're gonna do is like we know that
there's no physical evidence to get him
convicted of the murders however there
is enough evidence to get him on like
the Green Man like the sexual assaults
and all that other kind of stuff so like
we're gonna do that but F lee Bailey was
like I'm going to use the murders as
evidence that he's insane because I want
to get him sent to a mental hospital
instead of jail
because apparently that's I think that
maybe that's what Albert DeSalvo wanted
even though he said something about
Bridgewater where he said I don't want
to be stuck in a hole like this but I
think he would have rather gone to a
mental hospital than prison so they were
going to try so it's really weird they
were gonna use the murders as evidence
but only evidence that he was crazy so
that they could have him put away rather
than put in jail
for the rapes you know what I mean so
it's like like I said f lee Bailey even
though he was defending him he for sure
he was guilty he's like he knew too much
[ __ ] about the thing and he's like and I
know dudes and he's like I know the way
criminals talk and he's like I can tell
when someone's exaggerating or making
something up or you know repeating
something that someone else has told
them it's like and I don't think that's
the case here he sounded like he had
been there and he knew what he was
talking about you know so like I said
there's all these little [ __ ] details
that he knew about all the apartments
and everything like that now he also
said that he had attacked a Danish girl
in her apartment in Boston and this one
hadn't been reported because he hadn't
like you know carried it out or whatever
he says he talks his way in there and he
had like put his arm round her neck like
he was gonna strangle her and then he
saw his own reflection in a mirror and
was like horrified by the sight of
himself so he let go of her and then
started crying and apologized to her and
asked her not to call the police
and he told her and this is what he said
to the police he said I told her that if
if my mom finds out that I did this
she'll cut off my allowance and I won't
be able to finish college
what so the woman didn't report it right
now the guy like this Albert didn't run
like a Boston Strangler yeah
well she didn't know that I was like you
know what I mean it's because he didn't
get caught until a couple years later
right and it's like so he didn't know
the girl's name or anything like that
but he described her and he described
her apartment like where it was and
stuff so they found her and she
remembered that happening obviously yeah
as you would and yeah she identified him
as the guy that had done that
yeah so how do these dudes sleep at
night it's all those ticking time bombs
and like you do that [ __ ] two years ago
and then you just continue on doing it
don't even think about it yeah I don't
know I don't get it are you sleep at
night I don't get any bit like I said
they must be she's gonna change your
mind she's gonna call the cops they're
out to get me they're gonna be here at
any minute so I mean it's like even if I
you know even if I didn't have you can't
have any conscious a conscience yeah or
empathy or you know anything
like that and no sense of
self-preservation that's what I mean you
would think that at least there would be
self-preservation not even that is like
you know what I mean that at least that
would keep you in check like oh [ __ ] I
might get caught yeah evidently but I
guess not alive dammit these [ __ ] axe
is so strong that they just have to keep
doing it yeah it's like just compulsive
behavior but you would think you'd be
tossing and turning in [ __ ] bed
worried about that [ __ ] wait no that's
what I mean all the time saw me prob
about thirty of them have seen one of
them's gonna [ __ ] figure it out
they're gonna call the cops
you would think you don't I mean yeah
but this must be kind of dumb and
simplistic they do it they walk away
from the situation and like oh well
they'll never catch me I don't think
about it yeah I do think there's like
some arrogance and cockiness involved
like they think they're smarter than
other people they think that they've
like God got that [ __ ] sorted out
yeah she's forgotten what I look like
yes it's that kind of stuff yeah maybe
so like I said even though at this stage
you know the cops f lee Bailey everybody
said they're pretty much okay well we
got the Boston Strangler he did all of
the crimes however as I said there's
still like a lot of controversy over
whether he actually did all of the
crimes now there was kind of this book
that came out this woman named Susan
Kelly I guess she's like a criminologist
or something like that she is of the
opinion that she doesn't think Albert
DeSalvo committed at least didn't commit
all of the Boston Strangler murder she
thinks there was more than one and she
points out one and this is pretty much
true at the time she wrote the book at
least that there was no physical
evidence tying Albert DeSalvo to any of
the crime scenes like I said that is
largely true except for one case that
I'll get to later on she also said that
in the cases where and I kind of talked
about some of these before where someone
that they thought was maybe the
strangler was seen by neighbors and [ __ ]
like that because some of this should
happen like in broad daylight right so
it wasn't like nighttime or anything it
was like the middle of the day like the
morning or afternoon
now some people and then in the
apartment buildings had seen a man that
they didn't know like wandering around
the building like right around the time
that the victims were killed and stuff
and she's like interestingly none of
these people looked like Albert DeSalvo
who if you've seen pictures of him is
pretty distinctive looking he had very
dark hair it was like kind of like comb
back in a big pompadour he had like a
big huge hulking nose um you know what I
mean in suit she said so if this guy was
walking around an apartment building
most people would notice that and would
notice the nose at least they're like so
in some cases where neighbors did see a
person knocking on doors are acting
weirdly like in the apartment or
whatever most of those people described
him as being a bit younger than Albert
DeSalvo being like having like honey
blonde hair like dirty blonde hair like
not dark hair um didn't say anything
like a lot of him said that he had a
real thin face um you know and [ __ ] like
that so a lot of the descriptions didn't
fit Albert DeSalvo so she thought that
was a little suspicious also and some of
the people that they brought in later on
like after DeSalvo was caught that had
had apparently seen who they thought was
the strangler and they showed them
pictures of DeSalvo and none of them
recognized him so she thought that was a
little suspicious that maybe that
pointed to maybe there being more than
one or something like that like I said
I'm not super sure that I buy that she
also kind of pointed out that some of
the and and I'm not sure if I would buy
this either but she's like some of the
questions that they asked Albert DeSalvo
when they were you know the 25 questions
that supposedly only the killer would
know she is of the opinion that the
police were feeding him information
which sometimes they do like sometimes
they'll ask of leading questions or
things like that she thinks it was that
or she thinks that he was getting the
information from the cops or that you
know because a lot of the [ __ ] that was
in the newspapers and stuff like that
was very detailed and that maybe he was
getting information from that I'm not
sure if I buy that because as I said as
far as I know some of the details of the
crimes particularly like the one woman
that was left with her feet up on the
chairs and stuff that was actually not
reported in the media at the time so I'm
not real sure where he would have got
that now there is another theory though
that the guy that he allegedly confessed
to in Bridgewater State Hospital George
Nasser that maybe he was the strangler
and that he was getting information from
him because for real George Nasser did
look a lot more like the descriptions
like a people that had seen a guy
wandering around the building on the day
some of the you know he had like he did
have different colored hair but you know
it could have been dyed and
interestingly when they brought a couple
of people in that had seen this guy and
they brought it they brought them in to
look at Albert DeSalvo and they didn't
recognize him but they did kind of
recognize Nasser but they said well his
hair's different but he does actually
kind of look familiar
so some people have speculated that
maybe Nasser was the strangler and that
DeSalvo was getting the information from
him because he did it and then for some
reason he decided to confess to it to
make himself more important or something
like that which I suppose that's
possible but I don't know I'm not really
sure about that and like I said in light
of later events I think I mean they know
at least that he did one of them now
interestingly though and like I said
it's like some of the [ __ ] that I use
and some a lot of the documentaries I
watched were from several years ago so a
lot of them didn't know this at the time
so like you know Albert DeSalvo was
actually you know put in prison for life
for some of the other sexual assaults
and stuff like that but like I said he
was never put on trial for any of the
Boston Strangler murders or anything
like that everyone just assumes that he
was the strangler because he confessed
all of it yeah now I could dummy but ya
know well I don't know because I maybe
he just wanted it off his chest maybe it
was part of him he says you know I gotta
I gotta stop this maybe maybe that's
what it was it's like I do kind of feel
like that's what was going on
yeah it's probably maybe that's some
somewhere in his mind he realized he had
to stop himself yeah so well you know
where's Dennis think we think Dennis
I'll tell you what just salvo this guy
here yeah we've gotta get his voice
right
got no creativity no creativity at all
there's nothing really standing out to
me about this about this serial killer
no style no style yeah what a chef
well he certainly isn't to your caliber
sausage he's not like putting on ladies
clothes and masks and stuff well we're
not taking poles autography and what
it's it's artistic
we're not I understand it's just a photo
shoot you know all right
so yes oh very famously Albert DeSalvo
did not get sent to a mental hospital he
was actually sent to life in prison
and he was sent to Walpole State Prison
in November of 1973 he was stabbed to
death either by another inmate or peg
card they don't know because the crime
was never solved now allegedly the night
before he was murdered he had called a
doctor that had been working on the case
dr. ruby and said i need to meet with
you urgently tomorrow he had to like
tell him something he was apparently
really scared about something so dr.
Robey says okay we'll all come in the
morning and talk to you however that
night he was murdered
so that has also kind of fueled
speculation that maybe whoever the real
Boston Strangler was was like threatened
to expose him [ __ ] or maybe there was
some other kind of [ __ ] going on the
official story even though they never
did catch the person that murdered
Albert DeSalvo was that he had gotten
involved in some kind of like prison
drug ring and he was like selling drugs
for like a cheaper price than like the
cartel that was happening in the prison
so like you know so they were getting
upset about it yeah um however there has
been speculation there like well some of
the guards and [ __ ] must have been in on
it because a lot of like doors and [ __ ]
had to be left unlocked for the person
got into where he was like to kill him
I'm sure the guards are trying to make
some money on the side so yes so maybe
that was kind of but yeah he was
actually murdered in prison and like I
said the official story was a drug
operation but you know it was something
to do with that but unofficially a lot
of people have thought oh well maybe
he's not really the Boston Strangler and
like the real boss attorney was like
pressing on his nuts or whatever and
like killed
to silence them or whatever now as I
said for many years there have been
people thinking that he wasn't the
murderer his family has like been
adamant that he is innocent particularly
his brother and stuff like that now in
2001 they actually did a DNA test there
was actually DNA evidence from semen at
one of the crime scenes the last one
which I believe was Mary Sullivan which
I think was the last one the 19 year old
that was the only one where there was
like evidence that was still there to be
tested now in 2001 and I saw this on
like a bunch of documentaries and stuff
the test either was not a match or was
inconclusive I've seen other I've seen
sources say both things so for a long
time people were like oh well he's not
the Boston Strangler because in 2001
that's like the test said that he wasn't
like there wasn't a match right just
means inconclusive it wasn't it wasn't a
good enough sample that's that's what
they're talking about
yes there wasn't enough I'm showing bad
eye yeah I can I think that was because
you say so that's how it was so there
was like this kind of like nebulous kind
of thing after 2001 like where people
like oh well maybe it was someone else
maybe that dudes still running around
somewhere however in 2013 they were able
to get you know with better DNA
technology they were able to get a
better sample they had actually been
following Albert DeSalvo 's nephew he
had been like under not under
surveillance but they were like
following him around like trailing him
they were able to get a water bottle out
of his garbage and they DNA tested it
and it was a match because that was a
match they decided to exhume Albert
DeSalvo zs-- body and DNA test that as
well and that was also imagine he did
that [ __ ] so he at least did that last
one he did them all which I kind of feel
like that suggests see I like I said yes
I know the victim profiles are vastly
different and that's unusual yeah but
it's not unheard of he said he didn't
care long as they were women that's yeah
and like I feel like that's what he was
a sex addict yeah he was turned on by
all women I kind of feel like he just
went around randomly and knocked at
doors and if a good enough looking woman
answers
manner if she is all she's like alright
I'll do this one I just feel like he was
an opportunist yeah so I feel like they
were making too big of a deal and he
knew too much about those other crime
scenes that was him I kind of feel like
she did all of that I don't I don't
think there was more than one
there's just because look at the details
yes there was like little difference yes
one of them was stabbed yes one of them
you know was in a bathtub and one of
them little differences but in the
aggregate if you look at like the
general outline of the crime these are
almost all women who live alone or live
with roommates that are out these are
all women that you know he just kind of
like he is able to talk his way in like
I said he might have knocked at other
doors and they keep going with the
situation at hand you know the crime
scenes would look a little bit different
yeah that's all was but like I said they
weren't vastly different almost all of
the women were strangled almost all of
them are strangled with things with
items of their own clothing usually
nylons or bras or whatever they were
usually all tied in a bow which seems
kind of like you know that's kind of a
big thing I don't think these guys know
that they have a pattern really yeah I
think they just do what they feel like
doing and they feel like doing the same
thing a lot mm-hmm that's all it is and
I do feel there's some variation but
yeah like I said in my opinion and like
I said I'm not you know I'm not an FBI
profiler or anything like that but in my
opinion the crimes are not different
enough to justify saying that it's more
than one person I think it's all one
person and I think it is all him he did
all those I mean I think it was doing
nothing he confessed to he'd do them and
definitely you know after you know after
the DNA matched yeah in 2013 backs up
his story he did all this I think it
backs it up too I mean I I don't think
he was full of [ __ ] and he didn't you
know he didn't end up getting anything
out of it like I don't know if his
family got it I mean obviously a lot of
like movies and books and [ __ ] like that
have been like written about the case
but I don't necessarily know if like his
family I did that his wife or kids and
he did hundreds of assaults on little
minor things that he got away with yeah
[ __ ] was a walking natural
disaster like I said it's not unusual
because like you said he kind of like
seemed to start out with like breaking
and entering minor crimes and a lot of
serial killers do then it's like I know
you know and some sources I
said you know red said to that he's like
tortured animals in his kid and [ __ ]
like that so I do feel like there were
signs from an early age you know he had
like the classic serial killer
upbringing the very violent dad and all
this other kind of [ __ ] and getting into
petty crime like very young anyone um
being in and out so I don't feel like
there's anything all that unusual about
him so I don't really see you know how
people could think that maybe he didn't
do it
you know tripping I do feel like they're
true probably did all of these like I
said I guess they'll never know cuz he's
been dead for such a long time but I do
really believe that he probably didn't
need too much and then it's DNA backed
up a story on one of them seven you see
did them all yeah I kind of feel like
you didn't multi I don't feel like it
was more than one killer okay alright so
you want to wrap this up shut it down
good chip yeah I thought it was do well
I thought I found this a very
interesting case I didn't know a great
deal about it before I started going
into it but like I said I just saw coma
programs on him I did you well there's a
lot of documentaries about him and I
never actually realized that he was
never convicted of those particular
crimes like everyone just assumed so
like I said that's why you always have
to say allegedly because he was never
actually put on trial for him he was a
[ __ ] but I tell you what he was kind
of a basic [ __ ] really he's just
come at basic yeah I mean he wasn't he
was doing horrible [ __ ] obviously you
don't like posing and all that like [ __ ]
like sticking broomsticks up his jaw and
stuff but he wasn't doing anything like
he Jack the Ripper no tear like tearing
out people's hearts and their kids yeah
and he wasn't doing weird you know it's
no I'm not saying that's good I'm just
saying he wasn't doing he like weird
Pogo the clown John Wayne Gacy buried
him underneath the floorboards type
weird [ __ ] he just just come back really
you know anyway that's kind of scarier
because it's like I feel like there's
more dudes like this running around yeah
yeah because I mean people I mean real
killers that do like that real splashy
[ __ ] that's very rare
it's like it's mostly dudes like this
guy yeah well you know basically a
serial killers are serial rapist yeah
that's what they are and his MO and
everything and the way he's doing things
it's kind of like an old-school serial
rapist more that more than say like a
John Wayne Gacy I mean Ted Bundy type
you know who did was doing super bizarre
[ __ ] running around
those heads you know yeah cuz that's I
mean there is like there's a spectrum
whose a spectrum yeah you know it's it's
all warped by that old [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] that was time to keep tying
those boys to the boards oh yeah what
was his name yeah damn he was sounding
them up in that Yuri throat with the
damn glass rods and breaking it isn't
[ __ ] up that we know what that's
called we know a sounding is anyway me
food get away with me get away from me
with anything it's gonna be don't you
know no I fun fact I used to get a
Turner Stan Hansen 8700 wine store like
a long time ago I briefly had an online
store like selling sex toys and stuff
yeah and that was actually I didn't sell
a lot but that was one of my best
sellers as is sounding kids yeah and I
was like yeah I know I was like all you
freaky ass [ __ ] yeah YouTube
sex toy game that that [ __ ]
disappeared quickly I tell you what
YouTube imagine that genre is a ripoff
what Amazon I receive them as Amazon
yeah they give preference to the new to
new sellers but then you know I mean
when you're not new they want more money
from you to try to put you back up in
the algorithms well and selling sex toys
is always kind of like a hard yeah thank
you this last competition it's a hard
thing to come to me but yeah well not
only is there a lot of competition but
you also get all these laws because some
states I don't use no neg nowadays but
some states it's like illegal to sell
like you can sell
last I heard and if you live in Alabama
let me know but I thought that if you
lived in Alabama
I thought dildos were legal to sell but
but anything other than that I don't
think you can but like I said that's
going back a few years and you could run
it a visit you weren't ready to problems
like selling like across state lines and
they're likely Galland a couple months
that wasn't bad I think your best month
was nearly 2,000 bucks yeah I made a lot
of money yeah for a couple months but
they just kind of fades away real quick
like I said it was just interesting that
I guess because not a lot of people sell
like sounding kits everybody sells
dildos yeah you can go to [ __ ]
Spencer's on the mall and buy Noah's now
it is yeah it's the porn you gotta get
off that subject oh this make my nest
egg
[Laughter]
oh my goodness carry me yeah Dennis is
probably is you're just looking up good
I don't really understand why why you
know such a liberal like Tom cuz you
dare to call me a liberal okay that's
right that's how Dennis Dennis [ __ ] you
did it dressing funny the way you're
doing these clothes I don't know why are
you so squeamish Dennis to probably be
all into that he probably like let you
stick a rod up his hurry yeah but he'd
want you to do that she did church with
him we're gonna go to the church won't
burn just wait on it it's like other
yeah sounded that's what you would have
to do it the correct way it's like he
would probably he would have whole
scenario yeah in a head of like how that
[ __ ] was gonna work out right yeah well
so we are like this what happened Jesus
man what happened you don't worry about
Jesus right now we're gonna sound Jesus
would have been into that okay stop it
don't be watching us okay you can run
around at night now I'm kind of scared
he's gonna like come with this tiny
little knife like I said all right so
let's wrap up episode 170 about the
Boston Strangler case sorry it's like
poor Tom it is that sec all right I was
trying to see if it would come out your
nose but it did alright no actual yeah
that's good if you liked the show like
share subscribe on all your social media
share with all your friends and family
it really does help a lot you know give
the video like do all that get us on
patreon I'm go ahead and contributed a
couple of dollars a month yeah hit us up
on patreon.com slash there's a [ __ ]
podcast or if you'd like to give a
one-time donation that would also be
greatly appreciated and you can go to
our blog 13 o'clock podcast up
wordpress.com and there's a button in
the sidebar that goes to a PayPal
account that goes right to me and him
we're here and we'll be used for various
things like for the show new equipment
new all kind of things
keep the show going just to keep the
show going yeah any little bit helps a
lot and that'll do it for episode 170 we
will see you next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]